quand tu te rendes là dedans je regarde
des chocolats oui je connais gens
n'achètent pas
le prix que ça coûte
voyez la
90 par rapport à 83 89 centimes c'est
souvent les produits les moins chers qui
sont placés dans des bases de gaudi
michel à 71 ans il vit seul à toulon
avec une retraite de 850 euros par mois
c'est sous le seuil de pauvreté fixé à
1100 euros par mois pour une personne
seule et son quotidien c'est ça bien
calculé rwanda mais voir à pas lâcher
pour ne pas voir la calculette à la main
à retenir ce que les prix et a convaincu
rendu en course et quand je rentrais de
compte etc aux mains d'argent qui me
restent pour jusqu'à la semaine d'après
je vais à pied on gèle tous toujours et
pour remonter des pages on me dit elle
c'est en euros 42 le ticket de bus je
préfère comme je dis souvent une
baguette de pain par jour réduire le
manger de repas je mange un report par
l'eau je m'achète trop quatre paquets de
gâteaux des gâteaux secs 50 centimes le
paquet de gâteaux à six jeunes qui crut
chômeurs 3 4 gâteau après 17 ans de
mariage c'est une séparation difficile
qui a fait basculer michel dans la
précarité à cette situation se sont
ajoutés des problèmes de santé j'ai
commencé en descente 68 comme sauveur et
j'amenais le poisson de bretagne 1
marseille la remorque ont la charge et à
la main au vide à la main ont roulé
24/24 week-end compris la colonne s'est
pas tig et la d'aegis commence à
s'écrouler x qui a provoqué deux hernies
discales
et
travailler à noël interdiction totale de
travail anciens bénéficiaires de
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés il a
cessé de la toucher à 60 ans au moment
où il a commencé à percevoir sa retraite
en france le montant moyen d'une
retraite et 2500 3 euros quand on voit
le prix de la viande ou le poisson c'est
la folie moi je peux pas me permettre
qu'il met bien la bavette ou des des
bonnes viandes rosbif et c'est ça qui
est dur de choisir des courts kim est
elle-même sans calculer pour ainsi dire
le maintien dans le panier là non
comme dit et radins com tu pourrais 50
centimes et un euro plus cher non la
boulangerie tout à côté les jeunes
régulièrement du pain à poubelles et de
récupérer du pain à poubelles pour
mettre au congélateur chez moi
pour moi c'est la honte dans
pourquoi je ne sais pas plus je me dis
qu'il ya
des gens encore plus malheureux que moi
depuis huit ans mais chelle est soutenu
par l'association les petits frères des
pauvres c'est par eux qu'il a pu trouver
son logement actuel un studio de 18
mètres carrés grâce aux aides il paye de
sa poche un loyer de 160 euros par mois
on m'a fait cadeau de la télé tout dégât
d'eau ici chez moi me retrouve aussi m'a
été donné par les le un voisin à la
chaleur tournante alors le top du top et
par contre la facture là vous le faites
tourner
le compteur tourne et donc vous
l'utilisez pas seulement eux doivent
très peu pour les pizzas je pense qu'on
a beaucoup des retraités qui sont dans
la même situation il ya beaucoup mais
bon con qui n'osent pas en parler ou
comme on disait qu'ils n'osent pas aller
voir les services sociaux
décents justement qu'il devrait
qu'on donne les noms de certaines
personnes aux services sociaux pour
qu'ils se dépassent les voir dans qu'ils
peuvent pas des papys mamies pays bouge
pas trésor comment ils vont aller voir
une assistante sociale